der menschheit in städten und deren
grüne lungen werden immer wichtiger
gärten die anmuten die vorboten einer
nahenden zeit willkommen im garten der
zukunft
hightech konstruktionen sprießen in den
metropolen dieser welt anbauflächen
schießen in die höhe und erholungszonen
erblühen unter tag
wo früher metall gegossen wurde wo hat
heute ein vertikaler garten auf dem
ehemaligen sulzer gelände in winterthur
erwartet uns stephan ritzler seit 38
jahren ist die landschaftsarchitektur
sein metier
geht's nach ihm funktioniert der garten
der zukunft als gegenwelt zu unserem
abstrakten digital getakteten leben
gesellschaftlicher immer
paradigmenwechsel richtig sensibilität
und chöre und machen durch garten
eigentlich bis ideales und wird immer
wieder neu entdeckt und inszeniert wie
die garten bridge in london
in zwei jahren soll sie fertig sein 30
meter breit und 366 meter lang
den einen ist der gigantische garten für
175 millionen pfund viel zu teuer
die anderen freuen sich jetzt schon auf
die schweben der erholungsoase sie
verwendet und sie verbindet in den
figuren bindet und zivilen glycin sich
rouven theiss ort sind echte faultier
trug dazu bei dass london also mal ganz
gut nach einer pflanzenart und denke
dass ich jetzt plötzlich viel licht da
wachsen nah am busch will man auch in
new york city sein
eine stillgelegte hochbahn gilt als
ikone des grünen pionier geistes
pflanzenliebhaber aus aller herren
länder pilgern über die high line als
entspannungs ort geplant ist der park
heute ein tourismusmagnet
das portal zum hofgarten soll im
untergrund manhattens entstehen die idee
eine historische u bahn station wird in
einen landschaftsraum verwandelt dafür
wollen die initianten die sonne unter
die erde holen solartechnologien werden
den unterirdischen garten zum
funktionieren bringen
in einem alten londoner luftschutzbunker
geteilt es bereits prächtig sprossen und
gemüse für lokale restaurants wachsen
unter den led-leuchten
auch hier ist das abend gardening eine
hochtechnologische angelegenheit ein
bestens vermarktbare pionierprojekt
pflanzen entwickeln sich in künstlichen
klima ohne menschliches zutun entstünde
hier gar nichts ist das tatsächlich der
garten der zukunft stefan rottler meint
ja solche projekte sind für ihn durchaus
tauglich visionen wie städte grüner
werden können das oft mehr dünger und
schädlingsbekämpfungsmittel eingesetzt
werden müssen gehöre zu dieser garten
form dazu der wintergarten schicht war
es ein prima verhältnis im besonders
wachstumsbedingungen sind anders und
dann muss man mit eine andersartige
nützling schädling wurde mit mit denen
umbau und ein heißt hat das gift sei
kliniken oder das heißt einmal eintritt
zum schluss dass ich habe jetzt die
andere seite für den guard diskussion
es geht aber auch bodenständiger weit
weg von dem durchdesignten künstlichen
landschaften entstehen mitten im winter
tor freie anbaufläche schrebergärten
auch das sind für den
landschaftsarchitekten gärten der
zukunft
ähnlich dem gemüse eldorado auf dem
ehemaligen flughafen areal in berlin
stadtbewohner verwandelten die anlage in
einen riesigen garten nutzten ihn als
ort der begegnung kultur und sprache
übergreifend sich nicht der soziale
aspekt ist mindestens so
zukunftsträchtig und so essenziell
wieder aspekt wurde eine technologie für
die urbanisierung vom funktioniere im
sommer hatte sich die heimat finden dank
sehen setzen und ernten mutet nicht
besonders futuristisch an
doch in zeiten wo so viele nach festem
boden suchen ist dies sicher der
zentrale bestandteil vom garten der
zukunft
hmm